wait wait
please come out and be counted down
please come out of your homes to be
counted for the 2010 sentence
where I come from
where your mother comes from
we didn't talk about our bodies
we were given two days to forgive the
attackers before they returned
we hardly knew how to read or to write
but that day we learned how to vote
do nothing stay and fight leave
if we do not forgive these men we
forfeit our place in heaven
surely there must be something worth
living for in this life not only the
next
we know
we know that we are bruised and infected
and Pregnant and some of us are dead
we cannot forgive because we are forced
to
who are you
who are any of you
to pretend I have had a choice
foreign
we know that we must protect our
children
I will become a murderer If I Stay
we are not all murderers not
men have taught the lesson of power to
the boys and they have been excellent
students
but they are children and they can be
taught
have we made a decision
our choice will be your future
foreign